[Müzik]
Buraya gelmeyi en çok sevdiğim şeylerden
bir tanesi çıkana kadar ne söyleyeceğimi
ve her şeyi unutuyor olmamla alakalı
bugün bahsedeceğim konu farkı yaratanlar
oyunun farkında olanlardır temel konumuz
bu kariyer oyunları ile ilgili ilk
kitabımı yazmaya başladığımda ve kitabın
ilk satırlarını yazmaya başladığımda ilk
Yazdığım şey buydu farkı yaratanlar
farkı fark yaratanlar oyunun farkında
olanlarıdır keza buradaki temel
meseleden şu kendimi neden sertliklerle
lanetlenmiş biri olarak görüyorum yani
yaptığım her tür eylemin sonunda bir
Neden sorusunu sorarım o nedenin sonunda
da bir cevap bulmaya çalışırım Aslında
farkındalık dediğimiz hazinenin kendisi
olduğunu düşündüğüm bir yapı birazdan
bahsedeceğim şey biraz Aslında
bakarsanız sizleri umutlandırmak isterim
ama çok daha farklı şeylerden bahsediyor
olacağım keza fark biz farkındalık
aşamasına biraz farklı algılıyoruz Bence
bir bakış açısını değiştirelim istiyorum
Biz hepimiz Aslında bakarsanız bir
zincirin halkalıyız bir kurumsal olarak
düşündüğümüzde departmanları zincirin
birer halkası olarak görürsünüz sosyal
yaşamımıza baktığımızda da hepimiz bu
zincirin birer halkasıyız fakat biz
zincirin güçlü oluyor olması için en
önemli şey nedir
mukavemete dayanıyor olması için her
halkanın mümkün olduğu kadar benzer
oluyor olması lazım ki benzer bir gücü
kaldırıyor olsun Fakat burada bir
zinciri halkası düşmeye başladığı an
yani zayıflamaya başladığın zincir
Aslında tamamen dağılıyor Yani şu anda
müthiş bir sessizlik var birisinin
telefonu çalmaya başladığı bu ahenk
bozuluyor tabi Bizim burada yaptığımız
ya da kurumların ya da bireylerin
yapmaya çalıştığı şey bu zinciri tam
olarak bir araya getirmek bir mükemmel
olmaya çalışıyor olmak Peki yeterince
mükemmel miyiz
tabi
kurumlara gittiğimizde de insani olarak
düşündüğümüzde Hedef tanımlamasını şunu
yaparız
herkes ama mevcut durumdan Arzu edilen
duruma doğru yaptığımız bir yolculuktur
Aslında bakarsanız Tabii Mevcut durumda
çok fazla ilgilenmiyoruz Biz her zaman
Arzu ettiğimiz durumla ilgileniyoruz ama
burada özellikle acı veren taraf mevcut
durum analizini doğru yapıyor olmak şu
anda ne durumdayız hepimiz kendimize
harika zannederiz Şu anda ben çok kötü
bir insanım diyen var mı
mümkün olduğu kadar bunu söylemeyiz
eylemlerimizde gösteririz bunu
üniversitelere gittiğimde kariyer
yönetimi ile ilgili sunum yaptığımda
katılımcılara iki farklı seçenek
sunuyorum Eğer kırmızı sunumu seçerseniz
size başarıları herkesçe kabul edilmiş
bu insanların Hayat hikayelerinden
bahsedeceğim ve size onlar yapabilirse
Siz de yapabilirsiniz gazını vereceğim
Fakat bu gazı sizi ne kadar idare
edeceğinden çok da emin olmadığından
bahsediyorum ama mavi hapı seçerseniz ya
da mavi sunumunu seçerseniz TÜİK ve
yüküm belirlerine göre şu anda
Türkiye'de 8 milyon üniversite öğrencisi
olduğunu ve bunların her yıl ortalama 1
milyon mezunu mezun verdiğini üniversite
mezunu işsiz bir milyon kişinin ne
olduğunu ve genel işsizlik oranında 3,5
milyon civarında olduğundan bahsediyorum
yani topladığınızda işinden memnun
olmayanlar da birlikte toplamda 15
milyon CV geziyor bu insanları
içerisinden nasıl farklılaşacaksınız
Bunları anlatmak istiyorsanız mavi
tabi buradaki mevcut durumu doğru
algılıyor olmak için yaptığım şeylerden
bir tanesi devletin resmi verileriyle
kendi gerçeklikleri arasında bir bağ
kurmalarını ve en önemlisi bana
inanmaları için onları bir neden
vermelerini sağlıyorum nedenden kastım
şu bilgi vermeyi Çok uzun zaman önce
bıraktım Yani bilgiyi artık benden
almaları gerekmiyor bilgi her yerimizde
doğru mu yani bir Google'da şu anda
günde ortalama 3 milyar Google araması
yapılıyor 4 milyar YouTube videosu
izleniyor Dolayısıyla bilgi vermekten
ziyade insanların bana neden inanmaları
için neden verme üzerine çok daha fazla
çalışıyorum Bu çok daha zor bir misyon
bunu kabul ediyorum
çünkü Bilgi dediğin biz şeyde Aslında
her şeyi biliyoruz değil mi yani deprem
olacak bir bilgiydi bizim için fakat
yakın zamanda yaşadığımız Kahramanmaraş
hedeflerinde yaklaşık 50 bin
vatandaşımızı kaybettik yani davranışa
dönüşmeyen bir bilginin de çok işe
yaradığını düşünmüyorum devam ediyorum
Biraz daha Global gidelim insanları
öldürmek kötüdür ve suçtur bu bilgi bu
bilgi hepimiz biliyoruz ama dünyanın
farklı noktalarında insanlar
birbirlerini öldürmeye devam ediyorlar
ve kule tüm inanışlarda ve dinlerde
Aslında geçen bir bilgi ve günah olduğu
bilinen bir bilgi ya da ağaçlar yaşam
kaynağımızdır bunu biliyoruz fakat
lüzumsuz ağaç kesmemeye devam ediyor
halde hazırda bir şekilde kesiyoruz ya
da
yalan söylemek doğru değildir hepimiz
yeterince dürüst müyüz Sizce bu temel
bilgiyi almamız davranışlarımızı
etkiliyor mu şimdi diyeceksiniz ki
bunlar çok genel bilgiler yani Ben yalan
söylemem ben ağaç kesmem Ben Herhangi
birini öldürmedim bunu genelleştirme
doğru olmadığını düşünüyorum
diyebilirsiniz peki
ya yeterince elinize fırsat geçmediyse
desem yani arkamda gördüğüm ağacı kesmek
için size bir milyon dolar teklif eden
biri henüz karşınıza çıkmadıysa bırakın
1 milyon doları biraz fazla oldu 100.000
lira veren biri henüz karşınıza
çıkmadıysa ya da en değer verdiğiniz 10
arkadaşınızdan dokuzu Bu ağacın
kesilmesi gerektiğini henüz size
inandırmaya çalışmadıysa yapar mısınız
yapmaz mısınız Bunu sadece bırakın bir
milyon doları 100 bin liraya ya da
10.000 lira Yapacak çok fazla insan
taşıyabilirim bunu bu bilgiyi taşıyor
olabilirler ama şunu söyleyecekler tam
keserken elinde baltayı alacak günaha
boynuna deyip basacak sorumluluğu karşı
tarafa atacak ben sadece görevimi
yapacağım diyecek fakat sonuçta bu
eylemi gerçekleştirecek Dolayısıyla
benim inandığım şey şu; ya da
bilgilerimi toparladığım nokta insanlar
bildikleri değil inandıklarıyla yaşıyor
Düşünsenize Hepimiz bir çöpün çöp
kutusundan atılması ile ilgili temel
bilgiyi aldık doğru mu 6 yaşında bir
çocuk düşünün öğretmeninden çöktüğün çöp
kutusuna atılması ile ilgili bilgiyi
aldıktan sonra hafta sonu babasıyla
arabada yolculuk yapıyor elinde bir pet
şişe ve bitmiş bir pet şişe ve diyor ki
baba bu şey ne yapayım ve babası diyor
ki at kızım dışarı şimdi bu bilgiyle
birlikte
öğretmenine mi inanmayı tercih edecek
Sizce babasına inanmayı tercih edecek
Dolayısıyla babasına inanmayı tercih
edecek Çünkü güvendiği bilgi orada
davranışı dönüşen nokta da aslına
bakarsanız orası tabii bu noktada inanç
kısmına girdiğimizde çok daha farklı
fonksiyonlar devreye giriyor çünkü
inanmanın iki farklı fonksiyonu var
Bunlardan bir tanesi
ihtiyaçlar İkincisi ise deneyimler şimdi
inanma noktasına geldiğimizde Buradaki
en temel fonksiyonlardan bir tanesi şu;
Biz bilgiyi ölçebiliyoruz fakat inanca
ölçebilecek herhangi bir kaynağımız yok
inanca ölçüyor olmamız için de en temel
fonksiyonumuz tutarlılığına bakıyor
olmak ve bu tutarlılığı ölçmek için de
biz şirketleri en temel noktada şunu
söyleriz ölçemediğin şeyi yönetemez Evet
inanmak iki şeye dayanıyor bunlardan bir
tanesi ihtiyaçlar ikincisi deneyimler
ihtiyaçlara geldiğimizde
şöyle bir yapıyla karşılaşıyoruz kolay
uygulanabilir ve hızlı olmasını bugün
çok fazla istiyoruz doğru mu aslında
çalışanlarımıza baktığımızda Genç nesil
Gün geçtikçe çoğalıyor işletmelerimizde
ve biz genç nesille ilgili çok ciddi
sıkıntılar olduğunu herkesten duyuyorum
diyorlar ki her şey çok kolay olsun
Çabuk büyüleyelim çok hızlı alalım
Vesaire Vesaire
çünkü
Profesör Doktor Muazzez ilmiye Çığ şunu
söylüyor Sümer tabletlerinde bu gençlik
nereye gidiyor yazısını gördüğümden beri
gençleri sorgulamıyorum diyor
dolayısıyla her dönem aslında kendi
gerçekliğini yaratıyor biz bu gerçeklik
içerisinde hala mücadele ediyoruz ve
diyoruz ki bu artık değişmeli bir şeyler
yapalım sürekli sorunların üzerine devam
eden bir yapıdayız fakat Burada garip
sorular Ben bir tanesi de gençlerin
Aslında her geçen gün hap çözümler
arıyor olması hap çözümler halk çözümden
kastım şu Peki üniversitede konferansım
bitti soru cevap kısmına geçtik
arkadaşlardan bir tanesi el kaldırdı ve
şunu sordu hocam her şey anladım çok
teşekkür ederim kariyer yönetimi vesaire
ama nereden başlamalıyız
şimdi kendisine baktım dedim ki liseyi
bitirdin ölüm seçtin çok ciddi
sıkıntılar yaşadığın ailen ciddi
sıkıntılar yaşadı üniversiteyi kazandın
ölümü seçti ve sura da beni Dinliyorsun
Bence başladın ama daha fazlasını
Bilmiyorum aslında sormak istediği şu;
hocam sen söyle ben ona göre davranayım
yani hap bir bilgi istiyor fakat o hap
bilgiyi bilmiyorum Hiçbirimiz bilmiyoruz
artık bilmediğimiz de itiraf etmek
zorundayız onu ne yaşadığını ne
istediğini ihtiyaçlarını ailesine
kültürünü beklentilerini hedeflerini
sevinçlerini üzüntülerini
depresyonlarını mutluluklarını
bilmiyorum O yüzden onunla ilgili şunu
yapmalısın diye olmak hadsizlik olarak
geliyor bana ve bugün Aslında bakarsanız
Eskiden çok bildiğimi düşünüyordum ta ki
Onkoloji bölümünde daha önce hiç elbet
İçimizden birileri yaşamıştır yani Allah
korusun ailesinden biri bunu görmüştür
fakat Eskiden çok bildiğimi düşünüyorum
aldığım birçok sertif ika yaklaşık iki
tane Master yaptım 2 tane de normal
lisans bitirdim ve temelde bir yolu ve
birçok yaşam koçluğu vesaire
sertifikayla anlattım kendimi her şeyi
bildiğimi düşünüyordum ta ki Onkoloji
bölümündeki
ailelerin çocuk onkoloji bölümündeki bir
aile ile konuşana kadar Allah aşkınıza
bir ay sonra evladını kaybedecek bir
anneye ne diyebilirsiniz hangi bilgiyle
onu teselli edebilirsiniz
diyebileceğiniz tek şey Allah sabır
versin o gün hadsizliğimi Aslında
bakarsanız Anladım Ne anlatırsanız
anlatın aslında herkes kendi
gerçekliğiyle yaşıyor Dolayısıyla Biz
bilgi paylaşım noktasında çok daha
farklı yerlerdeyiz Dolayısıyla hap
çözümler ve aramak noktasında ciddi
sıkıntılar yaşadığı kesin peki
bu hap çözümler araya aradığını bilen
diğer kişiler Etrafta bulunan diğer
insanlar ne yapıyorlar
bakın
bugün Türkiye'nin birçok noktasında
farklı uzmanlıklar doğmaya başladı
takdir edersiniz ki herkes uzman herkes
uzman Yani bunu lütfen kimse yanlış
anlamasın ekstra bir yere de çekmek
istemiyorum ama metaforce yeni yeni
kurulmaya başladığında daha metabors
bile ne yapacağını bilmezken Türkiye'de
bunun uzmanlıkları verilmeye başladı
işte metaforce uzmanlığı adı altında ya
da bugün yapay zekadan bahsediyoruz
yapay zeka ile ilgili Yapay Zeka
uzmanlığı eğitimleri açılmaya başladı
nasıl ki Daha önce yaşam koçluğu
eğitimleri ya da astroloji eğitimleri
devam ederken ya da bugün şu anda sosyal
medya uzmanı kaynıyor her yer işlerine
doğru yapanları ayırıyorum Ama buradaki
en temel sebep şu; İnsanlar en masum
haliyle treni kaçırmak istemiyorlar
özellikle gençler Çünkü hap çözümler
istiyorlar diyorlar ki işte Daha önce
hatırlarsanız lokmacı ya da çiğ köfteci
açıyor olmak gibi lokmacayı herkes
açıyorsa ve herkes bunu yapıyorsa ben de
yapmalıyım inancıyla devam eden bir yapı
Aslında ne işe Yar Çok da fazla
bilmiyorlar Onun dışında
Pardon en kıymetli şeylerden bir tanesi
Bence de En acısı Çaresizlik insanlar
bakın Üstadım çaresi Hepimiz bir
anımızda hayatımızın bir noktasında
kendimizi çaresiz ettiğimiz bir an
vardır ve bu Çaresizlik içerisinde ne
yapacağımız hiç belli olmaz neye nasıl
sarılacağımız belli olmaz işte bir kitap
okuruz O kitap içerisinde bir cümle
Buluruz bir cümle görürüz ve o cümleyi
tutunuruz bazen birisinin biri sözünden
etkileniriz bazen bir filmden
etkileniriz ve bazen de bir istekozun
kendi hikayesinden
kendimize farklı bir hikaye çıkartmaya
başlarız Fakat bu Çaresizlik içerisinde
kendimizi ifade ettiğimiz çok daha başka
noktalar vardır Çünkü bir türlü dahil
olmak istediğimiz yere dahil olamayız
Burada iki iki bir aşama var ve bu
çaresizliği onlar o kadar iyi bilirler
ki size bir şekilde oraya dahil etmek
isterler İkincisi ise deneyimler Az önce
pet şişe örneğinde verdiğim gibi hepimiz
farklı bilgileri farklı davranış
kalıpları üzerinde değerlendiriyoruz ve
bunu deneyimliyoruz bu deneyim
içerisinde de artık burada sistemler
devreye giriyor bu kadar farklı insanı
bu kadar farklı bilgiyi farklı işleyen
beyinleri bir arada toplamak için
sistemler oluşuyor Bundan yıllar önce
söylediğim bir söz
farklı amaç var hayaldeki insanları bir
araya getirmek ve her birini mutlu
etmeye çalışmak senin bir deli olduğunu
ispatlamaz fakat Delirmek üzere olduğunu
Garanti eder bu gerçekten zor bir şey
kurumlar açısından da zor bugün insan
kaynakları faaliyetlerine baktığınızda
çok farklı kimlikleri aynı sistem
üzerinde toplamaya çalışıyorlar ve bunu
yönetiyor olmak başlı başına bir problem
bu problemi çözmek için birçok farklı
sistem oluşabilir fakat bunlardan böyle
en sevdiğim örneklerden bir tanesi
Amsterdam havalimanındaki Temizlik
işçilerin oluşturduğu bir yöntem
tırnak içinde
tuvaletleri o kadar pisletiyorlar ki
özellikle alkol alan yolcular
Tuvaletlere giriyorlar ve tuvaletleri
gerçekten pis bırakıyorlar etrafa levha
asıyorlar artık temizlikçiler buna
dayanamıyorlar Lütfen dikkat edin işte
etrafa hissetmeyin etrafı işemeyin
vesaire vesaire artık işin içinden
çıkamıyorlar en sonunda işlerinden bir
tanesi diyor ki; Ben bir yol buldum ve
klozetin hemen içerisine çok canlı
gözüken bir sinek koyuyor ve insanlar
artık o sineği öldürmek için tam denk
getirmeye başlıyorlar
tek dertleri sineği öldürmek ve ne
oluyor biliyor musunuz %80 oranında
neredeyse insanlar sineği öldüreceğim
diye dışarıya işememeye başlıyorlar
hepsine ortak bilgi inanç vesaire her
şey bir arada toplayan bir sistemden
bahsediyoruz burada Dolayısıyla
etrafımızda sinek kaynıyor yani her
yerde her yerimizde çok farklı sinekler
geziniyor Bu bir oyun bu oyun başarılı
bir oyun olarak devam etti o yüzden
diyorum farkı yaratanlar oyunun farkında
olanlardır bunun farkında olanlar kendi
gelişimlerini ve insanları bir arada
tutmak için farklı özgürlükler ortaya
koyabilirler ama çok çalışırsan başarılı
olursun artık bu hap çözümü
Çünkü
gerçekten çok çalışırsak başarılı mı
oluyoruz bir gün bir liseye gittiğimde
Gelin bu arkadaşa bir cevap verelim
lisedeki arkadaş yine kariyer oyunları
kariyer yönetimi vesaire bahsettim ve el
kaldırdı Hocam dedi Bu bir Meslek Lisesi
öğrencisi ya çok güzel söylüyorsunuz da
dedi hocam herkes çalışarak zengin
oluyor bugün bana vereceksiniz 5000 lira
maaş yarın gün kız arkadaşım olacak
sevgilim olacak ailem olacak buna nasıl
geçineceğim
hepsini iyi kötü ellerine telefona bakın
Büyük ihtimal ya işte Bitcoin ya da
farklı şeylerle zengin olmaya
çalışıyorlar Çünkü ışığı hızlandırmaya
çalışıyorlar işin temelinde Ve nedenini
en dini izler ne biliyor musunuz
Bu arkadaşın babası bir mavi yaka işçi
Mavi Yaka işçi oluyor olmasındaki
realite şu yıllarca kendisini ve
kardeşlerini okutmak için çaba göstermiş
bir babayı gördü sabah sekizden akşam
6'ya kadar bir böyle bir hayatı yaşamak
istemiyor ikincisi daha hızlı para
kazanmanın etrafında O kadar insan
görüyor ki basından O kadar insan
görüyor ki daha hızlı para kazanmanın
bir yolunun olduğunu bir şekilde görüyor
Gelin bu arkadaşa çok çalışırsam
başarılı olun değil Dolayısıyla burada
farklı bir temel var ikincisi ise işini
yaparsan başarılı olursun şimdi burada
şirket yöneticileri var Ve yöneticilerle
bunu paylaşıyorum Aslında işini her iyi
yapan kişiyi ödüllendiriyor muyuz Takdir
ediyor muyuz
eksik bıraktığımız Tabii ki belli
noktalar var Fakat işini iyi yapıyor
olmak Eğer patronun umurunda değilse bu
Eğer arkadaşların umurunda değilse eğer
çevresinin umurunda değilse İşini iyi
yapıyor olmam da başka bir şey ifade
etmiyor insanlara ve üçüncüsü şunu
söylüyoruz sevdiğin işi yaparsan
başarılı olursun ya ben seviyorum da
Patronum sevmiyor bu işi
sevdiğin işi buluyor olmak için başka
bir haritaya dahil olmak lazım tek
başına işe yarayacak bir çözüm belki
değil ve biz bu kadar telkinler
içerisinde şunu anlatıyoruz Z kuşağı Gün
geçtikçe Hani diyoruz ya Genç nesil Gün
geçtikçe yetersizliklerinden beslenmeye
başlıyor yetersizliklerini yeterli hale
getirmesinin ona en iyi yapacağını
düşünmeye başlıyor fakat meselenin güçlü
yönler ve onların farkındalıkları
olduğunu bir türlü farkına varmıyorlar
Şimdi size soruyorum Bu kıymetli
insanlar Az önce resimlerini gösterdiğim
Eğer maskeler ya da diğerleri dahil
olmak üzere bu insanlar
dünya hakkında noktalarında farklı
değişimleri gösterdiler ama düşünüyor
musunuz ki bu insanların biz umrundayız
bu işe başlarken bizi mi Çok mu
düşündüler bu insanların yaptığı tek şey
neydi Biz özü kaçırıyoruz onların mevcut
hikayeleri Tamam çok güzel ama sürekli
onların hikayelerındeyiz Onların yaptığı
tek şey şuydu
güçlü yönlerini tutkularıyla
birleştirdiler tek yaptıkları öldürdü
ünlü olmak vesaire bilmem ne onların
problemi bilmiyorum bunu düşündüler de
farkındaydılar ya da değillerdir
bilmiyorum sevdikleri işi güçlü
yönleriyle birleştirdiler Fakat çok daha
değerli bir şey yaptılar bakın
Ne yaptılar Biz bir türlü bunu ortaya
koyamıyoruz bunlar bu İnsanlar
kendilerine ya bir pazar buldular ya da
bir pazar yarattılar Dolayısıyla olmayan
bir şey üzerinden ya da olan bir şeyi
çok daha ihtiyaç haline getirerek
oluşturdular ve kendilerini başarılı
kıldılar Dolayısıyla Örneğin şöyle
vereyim istersiniz resim yapmayı çok
seviyorsunuz resim yapmayı hep müthiş
tutkulusunuz kendinizi harika
hissediyorsunuz bu konuda ve resim
yapıyor olmak sizin güçlü yönlerinizden
bir tanesi çok güzel resim yapıyorsunuz
insanlar bunu çok beğeniyorlar Fakat
resmi satamazsınız ne olur
bu resmi satıyor olmanız gerekir eğer
satamazsanız doğru pazarı doğru Piyasayı
Bulamazsanız bir noktadan sonra bu
sadece Hobi olarak kalmaya başlar ya da
resim yapmayı çok seviyorsunuz ve bunu
satabiliyorsunuz insanlar işte
çevrenizdeki insanlar sadece Siz
üzülmeyin diye bu resmi alıyorlar 3-5
fakat resim yapma konusunda gerçekten
yetersizseniz bir süre sonra bu satışı
devam ettiremeyeceksiniz ve üçüncüsü
resim yapma konusunda Harikasınız
resimlerinizde Müthiş derecede satılıyor
fakat resim yapmayı sevmiyorsanız Bu
sizin tutkularınızdan bir tanesi değilse
Gün geçtikçe
kanser olmaya başlarsınız kendinizi
berbat hissetmeye başlarsınız her sabah
işe giderken sevmediğiniz bir işi
yaptığınızı düşünüyorsunuz eminim
Hepiniz iyi kötü yaşamışsınızdır bunu
Dolayısıyla bilgi ve inanç sistemleri
için kurumların Ortaklaşa bir şey
oluşturuyor olması lazım hepiniz
birbirimizden Farklıyız farklı
gerçekliklerimiz farklı davranışlarımız
ve farklı inançlarımız var Bunları göz
ardı ederek oturduğumuz yerden Evet sen
çok çalışmalısın şunu şöyle yapmalıyız
hepimiz her şeyi biliyoruz ama artık işe
yaramıyor
bunun üzerine bir aksiyon almak zorunda
olduğumuz çok açık Bakın ben artık neye
inanıyorum
inandığım şey şu; altı Şubat 2023
Pazartesi sabahı 4-17'de
yaptığım yatağın arkasında yere çökmüş
ve ölümü Beklerken bir buçuk dakikanın
ne kadar uzun ömründe ne kadar kısa
olduğunu artık inanıyorum Bu benim
deneyimlediğim ve yaşadığım şey
Dolayısıyla insanların gerçeklikleri öz
hazinelerinde ve onların tutkuları
tamamen kendi benliklerinde lütfen
bunlardan kaçmayalım ve Lütfen
birbirimizi sevmek için Birbirimize bir
nedeni Çok teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]